What role do women play in relationship
to men or first they make themselves
conscious?
Let's not ever forget about that because
the.
I would say the primary role that women
have in relationship to men is to make
them self conscious and men don't
precisely like that.
There's nothing that will make a man
more self conscious than being rejected
and why?
Because why is he rejected?
Will obviously mother nature in the
guise of that particular woman has said,
you're not so bad for a friend,
but there's no reason that your genetic
material should propagate itself into
the future.
Right?
Well,
and it's not like men are exactly happy
about being made,
but made self conscious by women.
Right?
It's a major source of continual tension
between men and women and it's no
wonder,
but it's also the case and this is
something really cool and interesting to
know.
You know,
we do.
You've divulged dive,
divulged,
die,
whatever.
That's it diverged.
We diverged from the common ancestor
between us and chimpanzees about 6
million years ago.
Here's why.
At least in part,
chimpanzee females are non discriminant
maters.
They'll meet with any mail when they go
into heat,
which human females don't.
When they go into heat,
then any male is allowed access.
Now the dominant males chased the
subordinate males away and so the
dominant males are more likely to leave
offspring,
but it's not because of the female
choice.
It's not the case with human beings.
Human females engage in hyperthermia and
hyperthermia is the,
and this is also true cross culturally
and it's also quite.
It's just as extensive in Scandinavia,
not quite a bit of attenuation,
but not much.
Women mate across and up.
Dominance hierarchies,
manmade across and down.
Okay,
well that has to be the case because if
obviously it has to work that way.
If one goes up,
the other has to go down.
The socioeconomic status of a woman is
almost determined,
almost zero of her attractiveness
towards a man.
Whereas the socioeconomic status of a
man is a major determinant of his
attractiveness towards a woman and it
isn't as well either because that's been
tested.
It's his capacity to generate and be
productive and to share because that
beats the hell out of wealth.
Wealth can disappeared,
right,
but the capacity to be productive and
share,
that's,
that's a much more important element and
why not be chosen on the basis of that,
especially because women have to have
infants and infants make the women
dependent and the woman is just looking
logically,
rationally and from an evolutionary
perspective for someone who is useful
enough to give a hint to lend a hat so
women make intense demands on men and
it's no wonder,
but the thing is is that because women
engaged in hyperglycemia,
at least in part,
we diverge quite rapidly from
chimpanzees because the selection
pressure that women placed on men
developed the entire species.
Now there's two things that happened as
far as I could tell.
The men competed for competence,
let's say.
So the male hierarchy is a mechanism
that pushes the best man to the top
virtually by definition and then that's.
That's the effect of that is multiplied
by the fact that women who are
forgiveness peel from the top and so
that the males who are the most
competent are much more likely to leave
offspring.
And that seemed to be what drove our
cortical expansion,
for example,
which happened very,
very rapidly over the course of
evolutionary time.